[Musique]
on dirait qu'on va dormir ici cette nuit
Clarence
les représentants locaux ont déclaré une
situation d'urgence pour l'ensemble de
l'État au fur et à mesure que ces
tempêtes continuent de faire rage dans
le sud-ouest de la Louisiane
Cherif un bus rempli de prisonniers se
dirige vers nous
ils sont dans la tempête et ils ont
besoin d'un endroit où se réfugier je
vous demande à tous de bien vous
comporter
les choses au clair vous êtes chez moi
maintenant je n'hésiterai pas à vous
tirer dessus s'il le faut vous pensez
pas que c'est ça l'ex que ça craint ici
vous pouvez me dire comment un alligator
est entré dans votre foutue bureau la
tempête les a amenés tout le bâtiment
pourrait en être infesté si vous voulez
survivre à la nuit on va devoir trouver
un moyen de s'entendre
œil sur lui et un véritable tueur de
flic devant vous Cherif
on va tous se faire manger vivant
du poulet